j'ai un autre problème et tu vas
remarquer une chose c'est que depuis un
moment on penche on pense on pense sans
jamais se redresser ce coup-ci j'ai donc
on prend l'eau et on est en train de
couler
c'est un rêve pour certains un simple
voyage pour d'autres une croisière
luxueuse ou une traversée quotidienne le
bateau nous semble à tous être l'un des
moyens de transport les plus sûre au
monde pourtant il arrive que certaines
embarcations n'arrivent jamais à bon
port
il s'ouvrait à fait naufrage au large de
la Gambie le bateau de Geneviève
bourgeois aussi a coulé c'était le
naufrage le plus spectaculaire de ces
dernières années celui du Costa
Concordia j'ai eu envie de
les rendre sa vie après avoir approché
la mort en pleine mer
je m'appelle Patrice Auvray j'ai 56 ans
je suis un des 64 escapés d'une naufrage
du diola survenu le 26 septembre 2002 au
large de la Gambie
je m'appelle Geneviève bourgeois j'ai 55
ans je suis rescapé d'une naufrage
Concordia qui a eu lieu le vendredi 13
janvier en 2012
ça devait être un voyage romantique pour
Patrice et Geneviève une traversée en
mer partagée avec ce qu'ils aiment mais
le destin en a voulu autrement les
bateaux sur lesquels il voyageait ont un
jour chaviré
s'ils ont tous les deux survécu à ces
naufrages ils ne s'en sont pas pour
autant sorti indemne Patrice a même
perdu sa compagne dans le naufrage
depuis ce jour chacun tente de se
reconstruire et tout simplement de vivre
[Musique]
des fragments de bonheur un peu jauni
par le temps des souvenirs rescapés de
la vie passée de Patrice il y a une
dizaine d'années il décide de quitter la
France pour s'installer à Ziguinchor
dans le sud du Sénégal sur place il
rencontre Corinne une jeune femme
originaire de la région parisienne
très très belle photo
les deux tourtereaux vivent une belle
histoire d'amour en 2002 Patrice propose
même à Corinne de monter ensemble une
petite entreprise touristique mais un
événement va tout bouleverser
finalement on n'a pas le temps de me
répondre j'ai jamais su si elle l'aurait
fait ou pas
[Musique]
tout commence en septembre 2002
décide de retourner en France pour une
dizaine de jours pour voir leur famille
respective mais corinne est malade elle
a une crise de paludisme depuis
plusieurs jours on remontait du
premièrement Dakar les options
différentes étaient soit l'avion mais
ils étaient tout le temps complet soit
par la route c'était beaucoup plus
difficile ça prenait beaucoup plus de
temps c'était très fatigant et d'autre
part corinne est en malade il était hors
de question de prendre le taxi la
meilleure possibilité finalement c'était
le bateau
le 26 septembre le couple prend donc
place à bord du Giula ils partent du Sud
du Sénégal vers Dakar durée du trajet 16
heures Patrice a réservé une chambre en
première classe mais en arrivant dans la
cabine un détail l'interpelle
la clim n'était pas en mars j'ai ouvert
la fenêtre pour faire pour ventiler la
cabine et j'ai noté que le rideau
faisait un angle par rapport à la
fenêtre et cet angle était précisément
l'angle d'inclinaison du bateau et
dès le départ du bateau dès qu'ils ont
relâché les amarres en fait cet angle
c'est prononcé à augmenter le Djula le
voici le jour même du drame ces images
ont été tournées par un amateur lors
d'une escale à Carabane le bateau penche
déjà dangereusement à tribord il faut
dire que légalement le bateau peut
accueillir 550 passagers ce jour-là il
serait plus de 2000 pourtant pour
Patrice présent sur ce ferry pas
question d'être inquiet j'ai pu voir
d'autres blancs qui marquaient de
l'inquiétude mais moi je me disais bon
c'est parce que c'est des touristes ils
connaissent pas bien Afrique finalement
moi je connais mieux de ne pas voir ce
comportement de trouillard
et pourtant l'avenir va lui donner tort
il est 22h quand une tempête éclate le
bateau frappé par des vents violents
tangent de plus en plus je me suis
réinstallé sur mon lit j'observe le
rideau et là j'ai suivi le mouvement
en direct avec l'inclinaison du bateau
puisque le rideau restait à la vertical
mais je jugeais de cet angle qui
s'accentuait qui s'accentuait
il y a un moment précis où j'ai jugé que
le bateau ne pourrait plus revenir
Corinne m'a dit mais Patrice c'est
normal ça
je dis non coco c'est pas normal
le jula est en train de se retourner au
large de la Gambie pour Corinne et
Patrice les chances de survie sont alors
minimes le bateau est à 40 km des côtes
et il n'y a pas assez de canaux de
sauvetage pour secourir tous les
passagers
finalement on attendait la fin quoi
c'est à ce moment-là que j'ai vu un
éclair par la fenêtre qui m'a ébloui
j'ai dit à Coco c'est par là qu'on sort
par miracle le couple arrive à se sortir
de la cabine et se jette rapidement à
l'eau mais le calvaire continue il fait
nuit la mer est démontée et Corinne est
épuisée par la maladie
la seule obsession que j'ai eu à ce
moment-là la seule attention c'était de
de prendre de l'élan de la pousser de
prendre de l'élan de la pousser
alternativement etc tout en nous
éloignant du bateau et Patrice n'a
qu'une obsession protégé Corinne surtout
que le danger vient de partout les gens
qui sont en difficulté qu'est-ce qu'ils
font quand ils ont plus que une autre
personne à s'accrocher il s'y accroche
faisait tout noir on se sent accroché
par quelqu'un et on est entraîné sous
l'eau par quelqu'un qui est en train de
se noyer et il faut se débattre
alors que Patrice est une nouvelle fois
fois le drame se produit je me suis
décroché quand je suis remontant en
surface coco n'était plus là et j'ai
d'abord j'ai cherché coco débattant dans
l'eau pour essayer de la sentir
sous l'eau j'étais terrorisé par cette
eau-là c'était noir c'est un noir total
et l'eau encore plus que le reste on
distingue même pas le haut du bas etc on
sait même pas comment remonter en
surface donc j'étais terrorisé par le
fait de plonger j'avais plus assez de
souffle pour plonger j'ai commencé à
l'appeler personne répondait
je ne retrouvais pas très vite j'ai
compris qu'elle avait coulé
Corinne vient de se noyer
sous le choc Patrice cède à la panique
je suis pas su quoi faire avant je
savais qu'il fallait m'occuper de coco
mais à ce moment-là je savais plus quoi
faire j'étais complètement perdue jamais
Patrice n'aurait pu imaginer pareil
scénario
pourtant la réputation de ce bateau
faisait craindre le pire
Christian Buchet vous êtes directeur du
Centre d'étude de la mer à l'Institut
catholique de Paris qu'est-ce qui se
passe dans le cas du jour là à ce
moment-là pour le conduire au naufrage
plusieurs choses un naufrage est souvent
la concurrence de plusieurs causes
première cause quand vous avez un navire
qui est certifié pour quelques 550
personnes et que vous avez plus de 1000
disparus vous voyez bien que le
surpeuplement quelque sorte du navire
conduit naturellement naufrage mais vous
savez quand vous avez trois fois plus de
passagers que d'embarcation disponibles
on est pire que dans le cas du Titanic
alors quelle est la bonne attitude à
adopter en cas de naufrage tout dépend
où vous naufragés si vous étiez dans le
cas du Titanic et que vous êtes dans
l'eau il faut surtout pas nager pour
vous réchauffer même si l'eau est froide
pourquoi parce que vous allez bien sûr
vous réchauffer en agent mais vous allez
brûler toutes vos calories et 10 minutes
après vous ne pourrez plus lutter contre
le froid donc le plus simple
effectivement c'est garder son
sang-froid se mettre en position
d'attente et pour attendre il faut donc
pas faire de mouvement s'accrocher si
possible un objet flottant c'est le
bateau n'a pas encore sombré il faut
faire quoi il faut sortir sur le il faut
sauter à l'eau
on va vite chercher son gilet et on va
sur le point de rassemblement et on
attend les instructions alors on parle
souvent de liste noire dans le milieu
aérien beaucoup moins dans le milieu des
bateaux pourquoi est-ce que c'est un
milieu qui est moins contrôlé ah oui
très clairement le droit aérien est un
droit relativement récent vous n'avez
pas au moment où parlons un avion qui
n'est pas contrôlé ni en altitude ni en
vitesse c'est pas le cas des navires il
y a une liste noire effectivement des de
certaines compagnies qui qui existent si
vous parlez des pavillons de
complaisance on va toujours montrer du
doigt Panama Bellis Vincent mais
finalement chaque année ça se tourne
nous avons la chance en France d'avoir
la deuxième pavillon de plus au monde
avec une flotte particulièrement jaune
mais c'est pas le cas de certains pays
Patrice est sous le choc il vient de
perdre sa compagne en pleine mer au
milieu de vagues de 2 mètres à cet
instant il ne croit plus en séance de
survie et pourtant un coup de pouce du
destin va venir changer la donne
Toulon dans le sud de la France le
soleil la mer un petit goût de vacances
qui a pourtant un goût amer pour
Geneviève bourgeois
[Musique]
voilà le port de Toulon c'est ici que
tout a commencé ce que je peux ressentir
aujourd'hui de revenir sur ce lieu c'est
une
profonde angoisse beaucoup de
un stress une peur c'est la première
fois que Geneviève revient sur les lieux
où sa vie à un jour basculer il y a deux
ans son compagnon Roger lui offre une
semaine de vacances en mer Méditerranée
à bord du Costa Concordia pour moi cette
croisière ça devait être un rêve et ça a
été vraiment un cauchemar un enfant
[Musique]
tout commence le 8 janvier 2012
Geneviève et son compagnon s'apprêtent à
vivre un séjour de rêve à bord du Costa
Concordia j'ai eu la chance que mon mari
m'est offert une suite donc j'avais une
super cabine c'était magnifique
on est arrivé il y avait le champagne
les petits gâteaux
c'est le voyage d'une vie pour Geneviève
alors en pleine rémission d'un cancer
elle tient à profiter de chaque instant
sur ce paquebook il est merveille et il
y a de quoi selon la brochure c'est une
véritable ville flottante de 14 étages
qui s'offrent à Geneviève et Roger
cinéma restaurant théâtre piscine le
paquebot est surnommé le temple du luxe
et du divertissement
ah bah pour moi c'était il était jusque
gigantesque un seul merci c'était
évident bon c'était impossible qui coule
je même pas genre
j'ai même pas pensé je n'y ai même pas
pensé
le vendredi 13 janvier Geneviève et
Roger s'offre une escale en amoureux à
Rome et remonte à leur cabine à 17h
comme chaque soir Geneviève se fait
belle
ce soir là je suis habillée avec une
petite robe en soi et un petit gilet des
talons donc on se prépare pour aller au
théâtre vers 19h
19h30 on va voir le spectacle de magie
pour le repas c'était prévu vers 21h
donc vers 21h05 ou 10 on se présente au
restaurant Roma et on s'installe à notre
table qui surplombait la salle du
restaurant
[Musique]
il est 21h44
Geneviève et Roger s'apprête à dîner
quand soudain il secoue se fait sentir
tout un coup le bateau a légèrement
penché brutalement d'un seul coup sur la
droite mais pas très fortement juste
pour que les assiettes et les vers
glissent mon mari récupère son assiette
il avait faim
et
quelques secondes après
le maître d'hôtel se trouvant à côté de
nous nous parle en français nous dit
vous inquiétez pas on a du percuter un
bateau
j'ai eu le temps de me faire la
réflexion en me disant
j'espère qu'il était quand même assez
gros pour s'en sortir parce que nous on
est quand même énorme
et j'ai pas eu le temps de terminer ma
réflexion que là le bateau franchement
penché sur la droite et là ça a été une
catastrophe sous le choc les tables se
renversent les passagers tombent à terre
le commandant prend alors la parole
selon lui le navire a un problème de
stabilisateur et la situation est sous
contrôle en apparence mon mari m'a dit
mais panique pas il y a un incident ils
ont un problème de moteur ou je ne sais
pas
on va pas tous s'enfuir comme ça il m'a
dit attends ils vont nous servir à
manger et il s'est rasé
et là non moi je suis carrément monté
debout sur ma chaise debout sur la table
et j'ai sauté de l'autre côté je n'en ai
pas question
je veux sortir à l'air libre le couple
sort alors par une sortie de secours et
se retrouve sur le pont numéro 3 avec
d'autres passagers face à eux des caches
qui enferment les choux et les gilets de
sauvetage
Geneviève alors un pressentiment rigide
non mais attends il se passe quelque
chose de grave si c'était réellement ce
qui nous dise un problème de
stabilisateur un bateau aussi gros que
ça il tiendrait pas on serait secouru
mais alors comme ça serait pas permis
parce qu'il ne tiendrait pas la surface
de l'eau donc j'y crois pas il nous
manque j'ai un autre problème et je dis
tu vas remarquer une chose c'est que
depuis un moment on penche on pense on
pense sans jamais se redresser ce
coup-ci j'ai donc on prend l'eau et on
est en train de couler son pressentiment
est juste le choc ressenti quelques
minutes plus tôt serait dû à une
mauvaise manœuvre du paquebot alors que
le bateau donc j'ai les côtes italienne
il a heurté un récif créant une brèche
de plus de 70 mètres de long sur son
flanc gauche le paquebot de 100000
tonnes ne peut rester immergé il est 22
heures le Costa CONCOR va pas couler
dès qu'on pense aux naufrage on pense
forcément au Titanic assez cloisons
étanche qui devait le rendre à
submersible un siècle après on a
toujours pas trouvé la solution miracle
c'est un submersible si vous respectez
les routes maritimes on va même avoir un
Titanic 2 qui va sortir dans quelques
années c'est le même la réplique qui
leur lance son voyage inaugura
d'ailleurs va prendre la même route il
va d'ailleurs communiquer en expliquant
que c'est totalement assumercible
simplement si on respecte la
réglementation on n'est pas loin du
risque zéro alors si on prend un bateau
un ferry à l'étranger à quoi faut-il
être particulièrement vigilant si oui le
navire effectivement
avec les ferry parce que souvent
effectivement l'embarquement le
débarquement se fait très vite et pour
tout un tas de raisons c'est mal
surveillé vous parlez souvent de
naufrage ratés ou réussis alors pour
vous le joueur le Costa Concordia ce
sont des naufrages ratés réussis tous
nos freins avaient pas diffusion de
tragédie donc il y a pas de naufrage
vraiment réussi
le seul acte vraiment intelligent du
commandant du Concordia c'est de l'avoir
échoué lancer sur la côte ou là on a pu
procéder une évacuation rapide
heureusement ce même naufrage ce serait
produit au large c'est évident que là
nous aurions des centaines de morts donc
tout dépend un peu de l'encadrement et
on s'aperçoit que lorsque l'encadrement
est là on est plus en mesure
collectivement de faire face aux
naufrage et que la solution individuelle
n'est pas toujours la meilleure solution
Geneviève se trouve sur l'un des plus
gros paquebots au monde le Costa
Concordia et il est en train de couler
la panique monte chez les 4000 passagers
à bord
Patrice n'a plus grand espoir son ami
Corinne s'est noyée et il est perdu au
milieu de l'océan Atlantique au large de
la Gambie c'est alors qu'il remarque un
détail la coque du Djula flotte hors de
l'eau mon idée première c'était de me
faire prendre
par une vague et de me faire balancer
sur la coque du bateau il réussit à se
hisser sur la coque et aide les autres
naufragés à faire de même mais alors
qu'il pense être enfin secouru Patrice
fait un constat terrible
qu'on ne voyait pas nous-mêmes on voyait
les lumières des chalutiers mais ils
étaient peut-être à 1 km pas plus et il
n'approche pas
une attente insoutenable pour Patrice
d'autant que les survivants sont plus
nombreux que prévu à cet instant au
début c'était
un discernable mais
quand j'y ai pensé chez collé mon
oreille contre la coque et là
j'entendais très très clairement des
voix des cris des voies de femmes
d'hommes et d'enfants et qui appelait à
l'aide
c'était le sentiment d'abandon qui qui
nous faisait le plus mal c'est à dire on
ne comprenait pas pourquoi on n'était
pas secouru finalement on avait envie de
crier au secours mais à qui cela même
qui était là il ne venait pas Patrice
est finalement secouru plus de 8 heures
après le naufrage
transférer à l'hôpital de Banjul en
Gambie il peut enfin appeler sa famille
et surtout ses deux filles
à 5000 km de là c'est ambre la cadette
qui décroche à l'époque elle n'a que 10
ans et n'est pas du tout au courant
d'une naufrage quand je lui au téléphone
je crois me souvenir que
que j'ai appris qu'il allait être
retardée qu'il allait pas rentrer tout
de suite mais sinon j'étais pas plus
inquiète que ça en fait mais très vite
l'information circule au sein de la
famille
ambre réalise alors qu'elle a failli ne
jamais revoir son père
j'ai fondu en larmes avec ma mère on a
pleuré pendant longtemps toutes les deux
on pense à Coco si on avait peur pour
notre père on s'inquiétait pour lui de
donc elle était d'esprit l'été en fait
Patrice sera l'un des 64 rescapés du
naufrage du Djula
1867 personnes y ont perdu la vie plus
que le Titanic aucun des rescapés
prisonnier sous la coque ne sera sauvé à
temps
cela fait près d'une heure que Geneviève
avait sur le pont numéro 3 le bateau sur
lequel elle se trouve avec son mari est
en train de couler à ce moment-là elle
ne sait pas que le Costa Concordia est à
seulement quelques centaines de mètres
d'école pour Geneviève le bateau est en
pleine mer perdu au milieu de la nuit
c'est interminable c'est très très long
on pense à sa famille on pense à moi
j'ai passé à mon fils bien sûr
mais c'est surtout de la façon dont on
va mourir
moi les scènes que je me suis faite
c'est de la façon dont j'allais mourir
je voulais pas souffrir
quand l'ordre d'évacuation est enfin
donné certains passagers filment alors
leur embarquement dans les chaloupes qui
sont censés les amener sur l'île la plus
proche située à quelques centaines de
mètres
mais problème l'équipage du navire n'est
pas là c'est le personnel de service qui
gère l'évacuation entre approximations
et débordement c'est la panique chez les
patates
là on se dit mais comment on va faire
tu crois qu'il y a assez de Shadow tu as
vu le monde qu'il y a
jamais
là tu m'as dit écoute toi et moi on sait
nager
donc de toute façon on va pas se
précipiter se faire écraser en montant
dans l'échalots ce n'est pas possible on
va attendre on va attendre boire de ce
qui se passe quitte à sauté
Geneviève reste accroché à une rambarde
pendant près de deux heures finalement
une chaloupe se libère le couple décide
de monter à bord je crois que c'était
l'avant-dernière shallow qu'il était une
heure moins le quart du matin
on voit la deuxième l'autre chaloupe des
parties on sait qu'il y en a plus on
laissait centaines de gens derrière nous
qui hurlent qui nous disent nous
laissait pas une dame arrive avec son
enfant dans les bras et là ils l'ont
ils ont refusé catégoriquement que cette
femme monte dans la Chalot
et là c'est assez difficile pour moi
parce que je sais qu'une femme et son
enfant sont mortes
et je
peux pas m'empêcher de me dire c'était
elle qu'on
la culpabilité pourquoi
pourquoi je suis pas descendu à ce
moment-là
[Musique]
des conditions d'évacuation très dures à
vivre d'autant plus que le calvaire est
loin d'être terminé pendant 36 heures
Geneviève et les 4000 naufragés seront
ballottés de gymnase en gymnase sans
réelle explication et totalement démunie
face à la situation
[Musique]
Geneviève n'a plus rien elle est pieds
nus en plein mois de janvier et ne peut
joindre son fils par téléphone du
vendredi 9h30
au dimanche 14h ça a été mais
c'est interminables on est littéralement
abandonné on est considéré comme des
vêtes on nous parc on nous monte dans
des cas on nous parc on nous montre dans
des cas on nous parle on est quoi on est
des humains
alors quand Geneviève arrive enfin en
France elle craque elle était 14 heures
et
j'arrive dans le hall et j'entends crier
mon manque
et là j'ai dit enfin mon fils enfin mon
fils la virement je suis la plus
heureuse des moments
Geneviève croit enfin être sauvé mais le
traumatisme provoqué par le naufrage va
continuer de la hanter
Carole Damiani vous êtes psychologue à
l'Institut national d'aide aux victimes
vous avez d'ailleurs reçu des victimes
d'une naufrage du Costa Concordia est-ce
que la réaction est unanime face à une
telle catastrophe l'archi beaucoup de
naufragés on va remarquer un traumatisme
psychique
issu d'une naufrage c'est-à-dire que ces
personnes ont rencontré une menace
vitale elles ont cru mourir dans cet
événement là est-ce que c'est l'instinct
de survie qui reprend forcément le
dessus il y a d'abord l'instinct de
survie sur le bateau au moment du
naufrage c'est-à-dire que chacun a
essayé de de sauver sa peau en quelque
sorte et d'autre part chacun essaye de
nouveau à reprendre le dessus et
reprendre le cours de sa vie alors on
comprend avec le récit de Geneviève que
finalement le plus dur n'est pas le
naufrage lui-même mais le juste d'être
privé d'informations et d'être
transbahuté sans qu'on lui demande son
avis finalement alors c'est vrai qu'il y
a eu d'abord le naufrage puis après il y
a eu l'errance sur l'île du gigot ou
effectivement il y avait pas de secours
organisé tout le monde a été pris un
petit peu de cours mais c'est vrai que
beaucoup de victimes ce qu'ils disent
c'est qu'ils se sont sentis très
fortement abandonnés à la fois sur le
coup et dans l'après alors justement sur
le bateau qu'elles ont été les
différentes réactions qu'on a pu vous
raconter alors sur le bateau les
victimes ont raconté du chacun pour soi
c'est à dire que beaucoup beaucoup de
passagers n'ont pas été dans la
solidarité mais plutôt dans c'est
d'abord moi qui vais passer devant
l'autre et chacun en garde une marque
très douloureuse parce que même si on
n'est pas tout à fait dupe on a
l'impression quand même que chacun va
être solidaire et ce n'est pas le cas
dans ces moments-là qui représentent une
menace vitale le but du jeu c'est
survivre
[Musique]
Patrice est un miraculé il a échappé à
un naufrage qui a fait plus de victimes
que le Titanic il est même le seul
Français survivant on se fait un café
pour lui la vie ne pourra plus être
comme avant sa soeur Chantal se souvient
encore du choc qu'elle a eu quand elle
l'a vu à son retour
donc l'écrire moi je me rappelle bien
les portes en verre qui s'ouvrent et on
le voit
on a l'impression qu'il est réduit de
moitié
qu'il est vous votez enfin qu'il est
complètement affaibli évidemment tombé
dans les bras l'un de l'autre mais mais
l'émotion qui se dégageait
elle était
je vais pas dire déplacer mais
finalement moi j'étais vivant
[Musique]
Patrice se sent coupable d'être en vie
et semble avoir du mal à assumer le
statut de rescapé on a sauvé sa peau et
pas celle des autres et alors là ça
c'est terrible il y a presque il y a
presque de la lâcheté là-dedans c'est à
dire qu'on se demande comment on a pu se
sauver soi-même et puis pas les autres
ça a été le cas par rapport à Coco
moi je l'ai pas ramené vivante à sa
famille ça s'était terrible ça il me
l'avait confié et je l'ai pas ramené
vivante et ça c'était absolument
terrible il a fallu l'assumer Patrice
refuse d'être suivi par un psychologue
préférent s'isoler dans sa douleur
pour sa famille la situation est
délicate à gérer au quotidien
c'est sûr que c'est compliqué on n'ose
pas
rentrer dans sa sphère quand il se ferme
et malgré tout il faut faire un effort
parce que
on peut pas le laisser comme ça tout le
temps même si on sait qu'il doit passer
par ces moments renfermés de toute façon
mais il faut aussi qu'on essaie de
gratter un peu
pour essayer de leur avoir
et de lui faire redonner un peu goût à
la vie
et ça c'est assez dur de savoir à quel
moment y aller à quel moment pas y aller
vous en faites encore du canoë un coup
de temps en temps
le retour est difficile malgré le
soutien de sa famille Patrice se sent
incompris ça a beaucoup changé mon
rapport aux autres
chacun va raconter ses petits malheurs
du quotidien
est-ce que je constatais c'était que
c'était d'une manière des fois plus
grave que ma propre manière de raconter
cet événement là ça c'était c'était
insupportable comme idée j'arrivais plus
à revenir avec les vivants
alors pour se sentir de nouveaux vivants
Patrice prend la décision qui va changer
sa vie de rescapé il décide de retourner
au Sénégal là où tout a basculé
[Musique]
Geneviève est une rescapée d'un naufrage
celui du Costa Concordia au large des
côtes italiennes qui a fait 32 morts
pour elle plus rien ne sera comme avant
le naufrage la bouleversé mon quotidien
l'appréhension la peur la peur de
voyager la peur qui m'arrive quelque
chose le moindre bruit me fait sursauter
et même si elle n'a pas peur de l'eau le
simple fait de sortir de chez elle est
une épreuve
au niveau des transports je pense que
cette peur elle est encore plus forte
que je ne peux les imaginer puisque je
ne me suis pas aventurée dans le métro
je ne me suis pas aventuré à bord d'un
avion
ma vie de naufragés elle est d'envisager
le pire
les traumatismes de Geneviève sont
d'autant plus difficiles à vivre qu'ils
ne sont pas toujours bien compris par
son entourage
son compagnon Roger présent à ses côtés
lors d'une naufrage ne vit pas de la
même façon ce drame et il est monté sur
un podium et ouais moi tu te rends
compte dans ma vie je suis bien naufrage
je suis un héros
ça va beaucoup contrarié au point où
est-ce que je n'osais pas lui dire tous
mes ressentis je ne pouvais plus
l'entendre au quotidien quand il
racontait l'histoire de dire oh mais moi
j'ai pas eu peur
avant la croisière le couple avait le
projet de se marier mais cette tragédie
a tout remis en cause moi plusieurs fois
j'y repensé au mariage et j'ai dit non
moi je ne suis plus prête à me marier
c'est j'avais des doutes
Geneviève ne peut plus compter sur le
soutien de son compagnon et finit par
perdre pied
[Musique]
au bout de huit jours j'ai totalement
craqué un matin je me suis levé
j'avais réussi à dormir j'étais
président
pour aller où j'en sais rien il fallait
que je sorte
comment expliquer que deux personnes qui
ont vécu la même chose en même temps et
des réactions complètement différentes
on n'est pas tous pareils déjà à la base
on n'a pas les mêmes ressources
psychiques on n'a pas la même capacité à
s’appuyer sur les autres et puis les
hommes et les femmes ne se comportent
pas de la même façon par rapport aux
traumatisme c'est-à-dire que très
souvent les femmes acceptent d'aller mal
voilà ça fait partie de la vie parfois
les hommes ont des réactions un peu de
prestance un peu de mise à distance ils
ont tendance peut-être plus à se
protéger donc des fois ça peut apporter
des tensions dans un couple donc chacun
réagit différemment face traumatisme
quels sont les conséquences
psychologiques généralement observées il
y a tout d'abord le traumatisme
psychique lui-même lorsqu'il y en a eu
un donc avec des symptômes qu'on connaît
de répétition d'anxiété des vêtements
phobies qui en a qui peuvent plus
entendre parler italien il y en a qui
peuvent même plus prendre un bain aller
dans l'eau il y en a qui ne peuvent plus
voir la mer ne plus monter sur un bateau
etc donc il y a parfois un état
dépressif qui va venir se greffer avec
une immense tristesse et puis il y a
aussi des incidences sur la qualité de
vie donc c'est beaucoup plus complexe
qu'un simple tableau symptomatique
qu'est-ce que les victimes pourraient
faire aujourd'hui pour aller mieux
beaucoup engagé une psychothérapie ça
leur permet de se questionner mieux
comprendre comment ça fonctionne il y en
a beaucoup qui en ont profité et qui
vont beaucoup mieux fort heureusement et
puis par contre il reste encore en
suspens la question judiciaire donc et
c'est vrai que tant que le judiciaire
n'est pas terminé souvent il y a une
porte qui hésite à se fermer
définitivement
finalement Geneviève et Roger seront
dépassés leurs différences aujourd'hui
le couple est marié mais le chemin de la
reconstruction est encore long
[Musique]
après le naufrage du Djula Patrice ne
comprend pas pourquoi lui a survécu
alors que d'autres sont morts
[Musique]
salut Nico
il va finalement trouver les réponses à
ces questions grâce à un voyage qu'il va
faire avec son ami Nicolas
est réalisateur et ensemble il décide de
retourner au Sénégal pour faire un
documentaire sur le drame du Djula je
suis parti sans vraiment de synopsis
vraiment sans idée très précise plutôt
dans l'idée on prend la caméra on part
et puis on verra bien sur place moi
j'avais besoin effectivement de trouver
un sens il fallait que je trouve un
point d'ancrage et je me suis grâce à
Nicolas ancré aussi à ce travail de
finalement de reportage et
ben Nicolas faut le dire il m'a beaucoup
aidé là-dedans
ces images il les tournent fin 2002
quelques mois après le naufrage sous la
caméra de Nicolas Patrice retrouve les
rescapés cela même qu'il a aidé à monter
sur la coque c'est pas tout ce qui m'a
indiqué le chemin
là-bas Patrice rencontre aussi des
familles de victimes
avec les familles de victimes je me
sentais carrément adopté
dans ce genre de rencontre il y a un
effet thérapeutique on se pose plus la
question si on est mort ou si on est
vivant on est sûr d'avoir été important
pour quelqu'un et on sait pourquoi on
est vivant
se reprend goût à la vie et se donne une
mission être la voix des naufragés du
Djula il veut se battre pour qu'on
n'oublie pas la mémoire des disparus
alors il se lance un défi personnel
écrire un livre sur ce naufrage
ce livre Patrice va mettre plus de 10
ans à l'écrire 10 ans pendant lesquels
il va s'attacher à retranscrire les
moindres détails de son naufrage mais ce
travail de mémoire nécessaire à sa
reconstruction va avoir des effets
collatéraux notamment auprès de ses
filles de toute façon on le voyait
quasiment pas quand on le voyait c'était
pour nous parler de ça alors évidemment
vous comprenez qu'il avait besoin d'en
parler que c'était dur pour lui qu'il
arrivait pas à s'en remettre dans ce qui
a eu quelques temps de un peu
d'incompréhension et ne parlez plus
vraiment du reste s'intéresser à notre
vie parce que si notre vieille
continuait à nous on n'avait pas le
choix quoi de toute façon la vie est
obligé de continuer à cet âge-là on est
à l'école on a tout aujourd'hui Patrice
a remonté la pente
son livre est terminé et le relation
père-fille sont désormais au beau fixe
d'ailleurs sa fille est née Gaëlle vient
de donner naissance à une petite fille
Patrice est donc un tout jeune
grand-père
[Musique]
pour Geneviève rescapé du Costa
Concordia le combat est quotidien
aujourd'hui elle rend visite à sa soeur
Chantal qui habite à quelques kilomètres
de chez elle
ça va
les deux sœurs sont très proches
c'est d'ailleurs Chantal qui a été la
première à soutenir jeune viere
mon rôle c'était
l'aider être à ses côtés organiser sa
liste de courses
organiser
lui rappeler les recettes elle
avait presque déconnectée
elle savait bon son mari il y avait rien
il fallait l'aider à réorganiser sa
semaine
à tout enfin vraiment tout
de toute façon
mais Chantal n'est pas la seule à être
des Geneviève à reprendre pied
[Musique]
tous les jeudis soir Geneviève retrouve
ses amis pour une soirée un peu
particulière il y a quelques années
elles ont monté ensemble un club de
tricot et pour Geneviève ce club est
capital dans sa
reconstructions
[Musique]
les seuls à lui faire relativiser le
naufrage en lui a offert un petit cadeau
une petite bouée acheter une bouée et on
avait tous tout signé le club tricot on
lui avait écrit des petites blagues
comme ça et puis on lui avait acheté une
belle bouée orange là vous savez les
bouées de
de secours le club tricot m'a apporté
beaucoup pour ma construction
personnelle
après le naufrage parce que elles ont
elles ont pris ça à la dérision elles
ont essayé de faire des plaisanteries
j'en ai aussi riz
autant j'ai pu pleurer que j'ai pu grâce
à elle Henri le club de tricot un
exutoire pour Geneviève sur sa condition
de rescapé je crois que ça peut pas être
n'importe qui qui peut en rire ça va
dépendre de la personne et je crois
qu'en dehors du club tricot je ne suis
pas prête à ce que autour de moi on en
rit car si Geneviève n'est pas encore
prête à en rire avec n'importe qui c'est
qu'elle ressent encore beaucoup de
colère envers la compagnie responsable
du naufrage
Joseph Brian vous êtes avocat
spécialiste du droit international
comment expliquer que ce soit si long
pour obtenir réparation
il y a plusieurs raisons il y a un la
méconnaissance par les avocats nationaux
du droit du pays où s'est déroulé le
naufrage première raison deuxième raison
donc les avocats français n'ont pas
l'habitude de gérer des dossiers qui
incluent un nombre de victimes aussi
important qu'un naufrage comme le joueur
ou même celui du Costa Concordia
alors en tant qu'avocat dans une telle
affaire comment est-ce qu'on définit le
montant de l'indemnisation que vous
allez demander au tribunal globalement
c'est en fonction du niveau de vie des
personnes des conséquences que ça a eu
pour elle mais très souvent on se
retrouve avec une difficulté qui est le
la différence typiquement pour le gouver
la différence de niveau de vie donc
c'est une des grosses difficultés
auxquelles on se heurte pourquoi est-ce
que d'un pays à l'autre les décisions de
justice sont à ce point différente le
droit anglais le droit français par
exemple ne fonctionne pas du tout de la
même façon et c'est là que le droit
international prend toute sa place et
c'est un droit qui essaye de traduire
les problématiques dans des concepts
compréhensibles par tous les systèmes
juridiques différents les compagnies
maritimes ont-elles des techniques pour
échapper à la justice il crée toute une
série de filiales de d'entreprises de
personnes morales qu'elles interposent
entre la compagnie qui a des bénéfices
gagnent de l'argent réellement sur ce
sujet et les compagnie qui
matériellement réalisent l'opération on
parle beaucoup pour ce genre d'affaires
de classe action qu'est-ce que c'est
exactement alors l'idée de départ d'une
classe action c'est qu'en tout cas en
droit français chaque personne doit
saisir individuellement la justice donc
si on a 2000 victimes d'un même
comportement il faut qu'il y ait 2000
recours judiciaires l'idée de la classe
action c'est de dire qu'on prend ces
2000 victimes on les met ensemble et
elle saisit une fois la justice on va
prononcer une condamnation de principes
en disant voilà pour enfin tel acte tel
comportement est fautif et donc vous
devez réparer et ensuite on a à gérer
individuellement que le montant de la
réparation
typiquement dans l'affaire du Costa
Concordia on peut dire qu'il y est on
peut imaginer que la justice ira qu'il y
a eu faute de l'entreprise il y aura
plus qu'à juger du dommage des dommages
et intérêts à attribués aux victimes
[Musique]
c'est un jour un peu spécial pour
Patrice il a rendez-vous à Paris dans
une librairie pour présenter son livre
sur le naufrage du Djula bonjour
ça va bien ça va au Sénégal son livre a
été capitale dans sa reconstruction
personnelle aujourd'hui il savoure le
simple fait de pouvoir le tenir dans ses
mains évidemment c'est émouvant
dessus quand on le voit en réalité
franchement ça fait plaisir la joie de
vos enfants seront pendant une heure
Patrice fait part avec émotion de son
témoignage
Corinne plus belle que jamais mes
cheveux détachés
l'allure tu n'aimes
dans le public la sœur de corinne est
présente de beaux passages
c'était très touchant émouvant ça nous
replonge à chaque fois dans dans le
cauchemar qui a été le nôtre famille de
victimes
[Applaudissements]
le public est touché par le témoignage
de Patrice et le félicite pour son livre
ça me touche énormément de voir comment
les gens ont perçu ce livre ça fait du
bien on a pas l'impression d'avoir écrit
pour rien je crois que ça c'est
important
Patrice peut à présent se tourner vers
l'avenir un avenir qu'il conjugue
d'ailleurs à deux car dix ans après la
perte de son ami Corinne Patrice est de
nouveau amoureux celle qui partage sa
vie c'est elle Lina 45 ans et libère au
Sénégal en fait j'ai rencontré son livre
avant de le rencontrer lui et j'ai donc
pris contact avec lui et son éditeur
pour faire venir le livre et on s'est
rencontré en janvier 2012 quand il
devait faire sa présentation à la
librairie quand on s'est rencontré
c'était
un coup de foudre avec Lina ils ont le
projet de monter une maison d'édition
entre le Sénégal et la France qui
viendra en aide aux écrivains en devenir
je suis très très heureux très très
heureux j'ai un avenir enfin
au revoir tout le monde
[Musique]
2 ans après le naufrage du Costa
Concordia Geneviève tente de tourner la
page
aujourd'hui elle prend le train
direction Toulon elle rendez-vous avec
son avocat Maître Casanova
alors on va faire le point sur le
dossier en Italie le capitaine du
Concordia est poursuivi pour homicide
multiple par un prudence et abandon de
navire Geneviève avec le collectif des
rescapés français s'est constitué partie
civile pour tenter d'avoir des réponses
sur les causes de ce naufrage les
victimes ne pourront se reconstruire et
nous pourrons peut-être entre guillemets
passer à autre chose parce que ça les
rentrera toute leur vie il faut quand
même le voir je pense mais elles ne
pourront passer à autre chose être un
peu rassuré sur l'avenir que si elles
ont des réponses et le procès est là
pour ça et là
les victimes ne sont même pas convoquées
n'ont aucune explication n'ont aucun
rapport aucune traduction rien rien le
procès se déroule quasiment on va dire à
huis clos en Italie mais Geneviève est
déterminé dans son combat contre le
croisierisme elle fait également partie
de la plainte américaine qui vise la
maison-mère du Costa Concordia la
société Carnivale le procès américain
est là pour faire mal là où ça fait mal
pour une société à savoir au
portefeuille et plus ni moins donc par
définition vous êtes la petite société
du coin vous créez un préjudice le juge
va vous demander votre chiffre
d'affaires en fonction vous faites 50000
dollars de chiffre à l'année 25000
dollars ça vous fera comprendre en vous
en plus de la moitié de votre chiffre
d'affaires
la société Carnival a fait un milliard
et demi de bénéfices en 2012 la justice
américaine pourrait la condamner à une
amende de plusieurs centaines de
millions de dollars Geneviève pourrait
ainsi toucher un dédommagement à hauteur
de 200.000 euros c'est la seule solution
mais la seule vraiment de les punir ils
ont plus deux ans ils ont plus 4 ans on
peut pas la remettre la fessée pourtant
il la mériterait
ce que Geneviève souhaite plus que tout
c'est de faire évoluer les mentalités
afin qu'une telle catastrophe ne se
reproduise plus je souhaiterais cogner
plus des constructions de bateaux
gigantesques pour la pas de l'argent que
pour l'argent sans considérer les vies
humaines pourtant deux ans après le
naufrage Costa Croisière ne compte pas
changer de cap un nouveau paquebot est
prévu pour 2014 avec une capacité
d'accueil de 5000 passagers 1000 de plus
que le Costa Concordia
malgré le temps qui passe Geneviève
reste toujours très perturbé par ce
qu'elle a vécu
en septembre dernier quand l'épave du
bateau a été renflouée son cœur de
naufragé ses serrés j'en ai pas dormi de
la nuit je ne revu que ces images
ça a été très très fort on espère
tourner une page pu être obligé de le
voir et quelque part on nous enlève
quelque chose on nous prend on nous
prend quelque chose de notre vie qui a
été
tellement troublé et une telle peur que
moi retirée de bateau c'est me prendre
quelque chose et pourtant je sais qu'il
faut le l'enlever parce que c'est un
cercueil
[Musique]
Geneviève et Patrice deux personnes que
tout opposent pourtant ils sont la
preuve vivante que rescapés d'un
naufrage n'est pas juste survivra un
accident c'est aussi trouver la force de
vivre au quotidien
Patrice a réussi à refaire sa vie ses
deux filles et sa nouvelle compagne Lina
l'aide au quotidien à aller de l'avant
son livre La libérer d'un poids mais
malgré tout sa mission en tant que
rescapée est loin d'être terminée
je suis un témoin et je le serais tout
le temps
Geneviève elle reste profondément
marquée par le naufrage qu'elle a vécu
le traumatisme de l'accident dont elle a
été victime risque de la hanter à jamais
qu'est-ce qu'on voudrait en fin de
compte qu'on nous prenne notre cerveau
qu'on nous les fasse
et puis qu'on nous laisse avec les cinq
tours de croisière avant voilà ça serait
l'idéal
mais ça c'est pas possible donc faut
vivre avec